We just lost Brody Stevens just died.
Got off his meds.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he,
he didn't like the way it felt to be on them and you know,
so he's so hard.
That's such a hard one to tape because everyone loved that guy.
And to think that everyone,
I mean,
he has no haters.
I don't know.
A single person was like,
that guy was a dick.
No,
no,
no one.
Everyone loved them.
And everybody really hard from close friends to people who just knew him a
little bit.
Like I knew him just a little bit.
He was so sweet,
but he was so,
so tortured.
He was just in pain all the time.
And yeah,
it's just,
it's so strange that you think the thing that people like most is for other
people to love them and care about them.
And everybody loves Brody,
but yet he couldn't.
It just couldn't go on.
But I never,
I've never known Brodie to have a relationship.
I've never known him to have a special someone in his life.
And I mean that alone probably be very,
very depressed as well,
especially if if everyone loves you but you don't feel connected to any of them.
Right.
Like how empty that feels.
And that's the core of depression.
Yeah.
But it's also the core of depression I had having had depression.
One of the things that hits you is that feeling that you just can't connect and
it was yours coming about when your first marriage was breaking up.
I mean,
I have lifelong depression,
but I didn't get it treated until that point when it was like,
you know,
it was like,
uh,
yeah.
Cause of the marriage was breaking up and I had to fly to Africa twice in a
month to send my kids.
And I remember the time that like a protected a reporter from you all at the
TCA.
Yeah.
He was on malaria medication and drinking,
which apparently enough,
super sweet kind Dave was,
was going to kick someone's ass and I literally had to like hold on to him.
I kind of want to see that I wasn't,
I hadn't because that was,
yeah,
the thing,
I just been been flown to Africa twice and it just got back.
We did the tcs and I think I also threw a glass at uh Oh fuck.
I'm blanking on his name.
Tony.
Tony,
uh,
Jesus.
Fuck them blankets and a nice guy.
Sorry Dude.
We're handle Tony.
Jesus.
I love Tony's a great guy but I was like out of my skull and I just,
yeah,
well that was,
that was her partner.
I took his report.
You took his tape recorder and Duncan and his drafts and threatened to kick his
ass.
Yeah,
cause I was,
yeah,
I was drunk and I was like,
oh my God,
go ahead to do something.
Sorry I missed this.
I have to stop this.
Oh this is crazy.
Yeah.
Well then it was after that that,
that I just went on antidepressants because I crashed really hard after that and
it was like one the things about that go to work,
you can't do anything.
You were experiencing that combination apparently of the malaria medication and
alcohol is like a crazy conversation and then you add to that jet lag and the
trauma of being separated from my kids,
the malaria pills on their own.
Thank you.
Mentally I looked her,
I left Harare,
uh,
to the sound of my,
My,
my eldest child screaming,
daddy don't go.
Which even now I can't talk about,
Ooh God.
See,
it's not worth having kids.
No,
no,
it isn't.
Yeah,
I have one.
I have a 17 year old.
Yes,
it's good.
They're on their own now.
In the year you could just write him off.
Yeah,
that's right.
Next year he's going to call it.
But anyway,
if you are out there,
get on meds and stay on them,
like Brody should've stayed on his meds.
Well,
you know,
I just wish we could evolve known how he was and how close he was to that.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing.
It's like people who think like,
uh,
like suicide,
things that if you're close to suicide,
it's the most rational choice you'll ever make when you're,
when you're that close.
It just seems like the most sensible way to go.
That was the issue is because it's otherwise it's too much pain.
Yeah.
I heard someone describe it as,
um,
it's not even an emotional decision burning.
It's jumping out of a burning building.
It's like there's that choice into the burning building,
or was that feeling where you go,
this is not an emotional decision?
I mean,
there's no choice.
I've had two friends hang themselves as here.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean,
that,
that is,
I never thought I would ever say that.
They never thought that that would be a way that people would be going out
either.
Yeah.
Or remember what we had Drake say there.
Oh,
he was hard.
Yeah.
That was a hard one.
I knew Drake back in the,
uh,
essentially my open Mike days.
He was a,
an established comedian in Boston and I was just starting out.
Oh yeah.